it's evolved a lot when i started the
first show i was 13 years old and
most of the experiences and things my
character was going through on the show
were things i was going through in real
life and now i just
turned 28 and my character's going
through all the things you go through in
your late 20s it's just been really fun
getting to play the character again and
getting to see where her life has taken
her
welcome to the new icarly
i feel like i'm not quite sure who the
audience is for this show
is it for those who were kids and now
they're grown up is it for
kids today like who would you say that
this is geared towards when we first got
the
call about possibly doing the revival
jerry and nathan and i all thought it
was really important that
we really made the show for the original
fans
and the people that are now in their
early twenties or
teenagers or late twenties anybody that
really enjoyed the show from before we
put in a lot of like easter eggs and fun
things
we definitely made the show for all the
original fans we've had them in mind
from the start
and even though we'd love for new people
to enjoy the show as well and for
families to be able to watch
um it's mostly made for the people who
originally watched
this is your moment to shine speaking of
new people we have
newcomers on icarly welcome lacey and
jaden i'm so
excited to get to know your characters
lacey kick it off for us what has it
been like stepping into the icarly
universe
stepping into the icarly universe has
been really surreal because i am around
the same age as nathan and miranda
so i watched the show growing up and
then to step in as an adult
it kind of felt like i was in madame
tussauds or something the first time i
walked into spencer's original apartment
honey i was in there touching everything
i was like oh it's the jukebox oh it's
the bottom man you know i was so excited
i felt like a tourist
but the crazy thing is is that working
with everyone we fell into it
day one miranda's so welcoming so sweet
i felt like a part of the cast
immediately
jerry loves to give me dating advice as
well like i'll he'll swipe through my
hinge for me or oh lord i'm probably
going to get off there but you know like
he would you know i go on bad dates we
talk about that nathan's super cool and
he's super frugal so when i would tell
him i was about to buy another chanel
bag he's like um ma'am
so you know it's just it's been it's
been a great dynamic and jayden feels
like my niece
so you know i it's been wonderful jaden
i'm curious to know have you gone back
and
binged icarly or did you come into it
totally fresh
i did start uh binging the show but i
didn't watch when i was younger
i actually started watching it a week
before i got the audition for the role
so you know going to the first table
read that was really magical
getting to meet all of the characters i
started fangirling over people are
weirdly loving this miranda what has
carly
been up to when we last saw her she was
on a plane heading off to italy like can
you kind of give me a summary of what
she's been up to
well she stayed in italy for a while
with her father she went to college
it's kind of funny because a lot of the
stuff that carly goes through are things
that i've gone through in real life i
went to college when the show ended
and then it's also kind of crazy because
in the pilot episode carly's starting
icarly for the first time in 10 years
and she's nervous and excited and that
was exactly how i felt in real life
life's too short to hold a grudge and
yet you won't forgive me for that
leggings incident
you didn't tell me you could see my
whole butt through them i thought that's
why you bought them
we can really see that miranda you and
lacy have such a fun
chemistry together and such a fun like
best friendship
how did you guys find that chemistry
together off screen to play it on screen
i have to really give that up to miranda
the second that i walked onto set
she sat next to me and she said hello
and it was just very cute she sat next
to me real close and she goes
hi and i love to tell people that cause
she's just such a warm and sweet person
so the chemistry
came easily we eat together all the time
we go get our nails done like
she really feels like a friend in real
life which she is so i think that that
comes across screen
um as well it's kind of funny because i
actually lacey and i met
on a super bowl commercial stand giant
dirt
hole for like four hours a few years ago
and i literally left there that day
thinking like she was so nice
and then we ended up doing this show
together so it's just funny you never
know what's gonna happen in life
oh sam miranda will we get to
learn a little bit about what sam is up
to in the new icarly reboot will we ever
figure out what her status is with
carly and with freddie yeah definitely
we talk a lot about the sam character
and where she is in the pilot episode
and the character carly
very much still loves sam and always
will
and we all really wanted jeannette to be
a part of the show in real life but
she's just
doing other things and we're really
happy for but yeah we're definitely
going to touch on that in the show
is the elevator door still open that if
jeannette wanted to come back as sam for
an episode could that happen
anytime if you could describe this new
icarly in one word how would you
describe it
a few words a few words thank you
because i need i need
two i'm gonna go with millennial and
camp because icarly is big it's fun it's
weird it's its own world and i think
that we
really stayed true to that miranda jerry
and nathan really wanted to make sure
that
that was intact but also it's
millennials like the girls we come out
of college we got
debt we don't have the job of our dreams
we're not dating anybody nobody's
married
so you're getting to see millennial and
you're going to see weird fun
i love it jaden how about you because i
did watch the original
and seeing how like crazy and kitty it
was i definitely think it's now
crazy and mature very very mature
you know as you said jerry can now cuss
on the show
and you know there have been a little
bit of bad words in the show
but thank goodness my parents are still
gonna let me watch it
i'm kind of stealing from the end of
what lacey said but
i think weird and fun if i if i can pick
two words
definitely weird and fun i feel like
icarly was always a little weird but it
was fun to embrace the weird so i'm
excited to see that back
for sure
you